[Música]
es viernes y el cuerpo lo sabe pero
parece que los únicos cuerpos que no lo
registraron son los de la profe estelita
la profe en mí y la profe metí las
viejas de lengua y df vete
solo a ellas se les ocurre seguir
haciendo cosas un día viernes por la
tarde después de clases pero hay
valientes que las siguen y las impulsan
a pesar de que llegan a las siete y
media de la mañana con el solo objetivo
de encontrar un nuevo par de lentes para
mirar la realidad
mi colegio el paula montal se encuentra
ubicado entre los barrios villa urquiza
y villa alberdi para muchos gps es es
una zona roja pero para otros los profes
los chicos y las familias que lo
componen una oportunidad de progreso
desde el 2017 funciona en nuestra
escuela club de los días viernes de 14 a
15 30 horas y dependiendo de la
intensidad del encuentro hasta las 16
mates y tortas de por medio el club
invita a los chicos a descubrirse a
bucear en su interior buscando nuevas
ideas
aunque este camino implicará nuevos
desafíos nuevos compromisos nuevas
responsabilidades y roles en la escuela
demostrando que quieren superar y salir
de la zona de confort para crecer
en sus comienzos el club funcionaba
dentro de las asignaturas lengua y
literatura y formación para la vida y el
trabajo
pero con la prov está el y está mi
compañera pudimos ver que había chicos y
chicas que sentían la presión y la
obligación de tener que hacer algo que
no querían que no les gustaba por lo que
al año siguiente decidimos que el club
debía funcionar extracurricularmente
con el riesgo de no tener adherentes
pero nos sorprendieron
a comienzos de año se me acerca helio
helio está en sexto año
y me dice profe yo el año que viene no
voy a hacer la carrera de policía porque
la verdad que es algo muy rutinario no
me gusta la rutina a mí me gusta estar
activamente todo el tiempo crear y
descubrí ayudado por mi mamá que quiero
ser chef a mí la cocina me divierte me
apasiona
y además a mí me gusta viajar y conocer
nuevos lugares y eso también me va a dar
la posibilidad de trabajar
yo le dije el yo hace lo que te apasione
hace lo que te gusta
y aprovechen invita al club para que él
formará parte del equipo y contar esta
historia de lo importante que significa
elegir hacer lo que a uno más le gusta
de hecho en uno de los primeros
encuentros
acá el yo con una de sus creaciones muy
orgullosos con un bizcochuelo
se me pone la piel de gallina de
contarlo porque a él yo lo vi crecer en
todos los sentidos
en altura inclusive me saca dos cabezas
esta propuesta implica más tiempo en la
escuela
en un tiempo de aprendizaje respetando
las propuestas educativas de nación y de
provincia con un formato alternativo al
aula tradicional
qué tienen que ver con las prioridades
pedagógicas y el desarrollo de las
capacidades fundamentales
pero la experiencia de club ted nos
ayuda a trabajar una capacidad
que no la vemos pero que está y sólo se
busca un solo se encuentra haciendo
turismo interior como dice la licenciada
liliana gonzález o simplemente
turisteando como dice doña jovita
aprender a desarrollar la capacidad de
la resiliencia ayuda a chicos ya grandes
a descubrir las fortalezas y los valores
más íntimos
esta propuesta de club te implica
innovar en el aula implica estar
dispuestos a cambiar
más tiempo en el aula sí o más tiempo en
la escuela sí pero en un tiempo distinto
un tiempo en el que se construye con el
otro un tiempo en el que se aprende con
el otro un tiempo en donde los lazos
afectivos son mucho más fuertes se
aprende a mirar escuchando al otro
siento que soy y quizás para muchos de
los que formamos parte de clubes ted se
sientan reflejados parte de una
comunidad que trabaja unida
con aciertos y con errores
con éxitos pero sin ante haber probado
el fracaso
chicos chicas y por qué no profes que
formamos parte del equipo damos cuenta
del gran trabajo que hay detrás de
escena
cada viernes una nueva lámpara se
enciende para dar vida a las ideas
en el evento t de ex córdoba 2017
escucha decir
mientras más te involucres más te
beneficiarás
y doy fe que es así
hace 15 años cuando yo recién entraba a
la escuela
una colega me dijo
mírame ti que acá no te van a dar
medallas por todo lo que haces
pero hasta no hace mucho tiempo me di
cuenta que esas medallas brillan cada
vez que yo pongo un pie en la escuela
esas medallas son los ojos de los chicos
sus miradas el regalo más hermoso que me
impulsan que me animan y me desafían a
dar lo mejor de mí
quizás eso fue lo que hoy me impulsó
subir acá y contar mi experiencia
[Aplausos]
[Música]